it's familiar but it's at the same time
you know it's it's different tonight uh
just cuz it's the first time being
back not playing here for the home
[Applause] team Eric Carlson makes his return
to the tank tonight with his third Norris
Trophy under his belt and a big penguin
in blazent across his chest which will no
doubt be strange for both Eric and his former
teammates it's a lot more than just hockey I
think you know obviously uh that's why I was
here but a big part of my life and my family's
life was was created and experienced here so
it's nice being back we have to be the most
determined team out there all the little things
that we talk about all the time that add up to
winning right it's not just about outscoring
teams it's about outplaying teams it's about
out competing teams that's the mindset that
we have to have all right let's have a good
night here come on starting up front we got
Rusty gy Sid on the back end me Marcus and in
that back in the building the San J sharks
here in front of the home crowd still looking
for that elusive first victory of the season
and tonight they'll try and get it against a
familiar face as ek65 returns as an opponent
I've had the privilege to be able to play
with Carl for four years it's been pretty
special to be able to play alongside him
and learn from from the uh the talent that He
has and good luck to Carl but uh I hope we beat
him he and Anthony duclair just got into it a
little bit through right in front of you peny
coming up right now it's going to be to declare
or a little bit too much on that situation here's
Smith driving one and scores Riley Smith to the
penous top shelf and a PPG for PGH gives the pens
a one- nothing lead welcome back Eric Carlson and
thank you for five great seasons in San [Applause]
Jose
St nor Riley Smith over the line he's got
Malin finds him drops it for rust cross eyes
pson centering and they score Riley Smith
with a slam dunk and the Penguins go up to
zip good job Dino hey good play eh no Panic in
that game I like it so like if the demon comes
I chip it by but when he does if I give it to
him then he can self chip and we can probably
change but if I chip it we can't change cuz
then they'll just turn rust Barrels in after
the puck centers in front deflected in they
score St gentel crash in the creas the pens
are up three nothing career goal [Applause]
200 but it's fine it's not you get by that
guy you're in you know 's control off the
draw across it comes the m and a shot score
[Applause]
good job hey 19 Sydney Crosby will
celebrate a milestone tonight playing
in his 1200th game Crosby stepping ahead
of the pack drops it for a tank backhander
score the pens making it look too easy that's
called chemistry that's called chemistry
forget what's happened focus on your next
ship you got enough of him you got enough
in his hands it's quick I I know what I'm not
going to argue you for it I just think I did
a pretty good job well you did but it's but
I did a good job doing my job 51 seconds you
man disadvantage going to kill off another one
here M Kyle grin put it out in front missed by
declair McDonald give and go blast four and
it is a power play goal the shot from Jacob
McDonald second goal for San Jose it is 8 to2 you
want to do Boston or no no no B go right back to
work gensel in front of redirect and bu chance
was denied it's loose it's in gel was whack it
away and he slides it over the line once more
and the penguins have put up a 10 spot in San
Jose and a Victorious and emphatic start to
this California trip as the Penguins stop
the S sharks 10 to2 I'm obviously very happy
about the game that we played today and the
focus for us was to take care of our our own
business and worry about ourselves and and I
I think we executed that and did that uh you
know as well as we possibly could but at the
same time you still have a lot of people over
there that I care deeply about on a personal
level and it's not fun to see them go through
what they're going through and I know that
they're going to be okay over there and and I'm
happy that hopefully this can start something for
us